all right so shannon
shannon uh tell me about your family uh
your parents were related do you think
yes cousins your parents were cousins
yeah i met goes on here in west virginia
doesn't it unfortunately and you told me
your grandparents
were also related either my
great-grandparents or my
i think she said my great-grandparents
but i know she said one set of my
grandparents were
cousins and also i was like ugh and you
grew up where
clarksburg west virginia not too far
from here clarksburg
the the center of the state right and
tell me about your childhood how was it
abusive and dysfunctional
in what ways sexual abuse physical
emotional mental from who
all family members like
my dad my brother my cousin my mother
my brother my uncle
at what age did this start it started at
five
and went on for how long as long as i
lived with my dad the
breaking point was i went to um
in my room and ended up getting my back
broke
with a 2x4 from my father
ty i met my first husband he was a
sergeant cop
so you were married yes
he's deceased though and how was that
marriage
abusive but at that age i was 19
and i just wanted security
when you say abusive what kind of stuff
happened
he the my first husband
got this finger off with a turkey cutter
like
knife and then broke this to the point i
had to have surgery
and it a pin put in it and then it got
um
infected with green gangrene and he
then they had to take it
so you lost two fingers yes
from abuse and you told me one of them
was because he slammed your finger in
the car door on purpose yeah
it was bad because he's there and
like when he caught the house was on
fire two months
apart then like he acted like the big
hero for coming to the hospital
and like acting like he was shocked but
he knew he'd done it all along
wow and you were married a second time
yes he is abusive but he kicked me in my
back where i had
had surgery just right before
and i should have left then but
i always felt like i had to have a man
to make me important
do you feel like the childhood you had
kind of led you on this path of
abusive relationships and very much so
being attracted to men
very much so are capable of that
it was the abuse was so bad that my mama
said
the other day that her and granny is
talking and
i could go turn to a woman
or i could marry a black man because
black men sit there and
take care of their women
do you have children i have two grown
when he when don cut the house on fire
they were taken and then my dad because
of
being so rich sit there and paid the um
judges and dhhr off to get custody
so they're in florida now and i haven't
got to see or hear from them
since 2005. yes
they said that was part of the reason i
had my massive heart attack in 2015.
you had a heart attack
so your first husband burned down the
house
yeah the the first one don he burnt
the first house he started in our
daughter's bedroom in the closet and
then
like three days short of it being two
months apart
then it ended up having another one
but his the officers below him
came to me each privately three of them
saying if i'd leave and i couldn't
because i still believe him for his
salvation
which did happen is religion a big part
of your life
yes sir and which religion do you follow
just christianity believing in the
trinity
i tried doing right i tried being good
people
doing the right thing but i'm not
perfect
far from it
do you have any relationship today with
your parents and your family
my mama and my grandmother is fiction
passed away
and but i call her mom too because she
raised me when i
pretty much when the sexual abuse like
whenever she could get me
she had me but she's fixing to pass so
but yeah she wants me and mama to be
real close when she passes
we've come a long way though
so you have some kind of relationship
with her yeah
i told her i forgave her only problem is
i have a real
difficult time forgiving myself because
my dad
demanded perfection
how old are you now i'll be 44 november
the 30th of this year
what's the hardest part of your life
today self-acceptance
um not beating myself up over
like it i think from my childhood
i expect to be perfect because that's
what dad demanded
and i was always scared i get beat or
sexually abused so i always try to be
good enough
and
i wanted to go back to college
and make people proud
it's like i'm not good enough for myself
[Music]
mama says you need to love yourself but
when i look at myself
i can't say that i do
uh parts of me but if i dare make a
mistake i cannot let myself flip it down
and you see the relationship between
your childhood and where you are today
right yeah
i mean counseling or at least i was
before i moved up here
but so many people was begging me to
come back
and you can
run from your problems
and but until you get the quote-unquote
balls to face them
they're always going to haunt you and
like i used to be an addict thinking
that that would be if i know myself that
it wouldn't
exist and
but yeah i i've tried numbing
i've tried killing myself
like the earliest attempt well there's
only been two
actual attempts and one was when i was
seven right after my
um chosen to there and had sexually
abused me
and my mom just walked in as i was
fixing to push their knife
i still have a little invention to my in
my chest
from it and you were using drugs at one
point
oh yeah bad bad yeah it helps you forget
yeah it was like pretty much like a
numbing
agent and it was so bad that
i was dating a um dealer
and was one i'd ask him why there were
so many people in and out
he never would tell me but um
oh yeah major crack addict and then i
told god if you don't give me opposite
i'm gonna die
and instantly in that moment he answered
have you used since um
not of crack i've used meth like three
times in heroin three times
i shot up once um
well no twice they did something called
k4
i don't know what it was but today you
don't use
no do you drink occasionally
i try i try not to make a habit of it
that's not a problem
right it doesn't control me anymore
thank god
where do you hope your life goes from
here you seem to have a good handle on
on your issues i'd like to help other
women and men because a lot of people
have the misconception
that men don't get abused and yet i had
a best friend that did
so i hope to be like a abuse counselor
one day i think by helping others you
can help yourself
too right you're only as sick as your
secrets
and that's a big family secret
all right shannon thank you so much for
telling your story
thank you good luck with everything
you too thank you
you